hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play
paranormal now if you're going hey
didn't you already play paranormal yes
you're right you silly [ __ ] but that's
a whole different story it's been
updated twice it's actually been the
full release and then it got to 1.1 so
apparently there are new scares and
there's a whole nother game mode or
something now to know anyway I'm not
sure what's different but I know there's
more stuff and I also know that I also
didn't actually get to all this stuff
that I thought I was gonna get to before
if that made any sense at all okay ah
see see it's different different there's
a full recording and then there's the
quick recording which i think is the
mode where it just gets did it Gareth so
I'm gonna do that one it's Friday
God July first Disney alone again hello
my name is motoki lark I'm an artist no
you're not I've come to believe that my
house is holy okay things have been
going bump in the night cameras around
my studio and I've got one here and I've
started recording things to try and
prove to people that I'm not going crazy
oh this is where the magic happens oh
don't mind the posing mannequins I
picked those up at Amazon they help me
visualize the 3d space when I'm working
on my soldiers some works in progress
over there on the man yeah they look
like [ __ ]
hopefully something will happen here in
a second hmm okay are you trying to show
that yeah yeah yeah I'm not trying to
get famous on yeah yeah yeah I am okay
now come on let's have oh oh hello hi
there okay mr. mannequin so far looks
all familiar who's this
is that a painting of my garage no it's
a picture of my garage is that there
before I don't know no dammit dammit no
dammit
okay so I'm gonna try to find anything
that's new here it said it's the bridge
version ergo I would assume hello oh
okay no shadow moved I was so frightened
I couldn't barely keep my panties off
what who did that who just broke
something is that in the kitchen huh
better hurry knocking only run for two
seconds spurts apparently okay knife no
city phone nope wait what what oh my god
God the stupid thing where my head goes
weird sorry I have a neck problem inner
ear problems okay was that a dog bowl
cat Bowl oh yeah my dog is dead I
remember that
that's so far it all look the same
raining outside that's new
come on scare me oh oh it's so
frightening hey wait a minute was
raining up oh nevermind it's raining no
that's not my go see my dog cuz he's
supposedly dead look hey knock that over
wrists in peace huh what done go through
that rock who the hell have the audacity
oh my phone
that's my phone hang on I'll get it I'll
get it I got it excuse me
Paranormal Activity my ass
hello okay yeah click I thought we were
just having a funny joke said it Oh
still funny
[Laughter]
okay dammit I thought this was gonna be
the abridged version where's this skier
not scary not even a little bit let's go
up to the attic ha ha Oh nuts scary
Oh what's this a ladder up into the
attic I actually don't like this oh
what's that again nothing
hey I've already activated hmm
actually one thing in the passion note
said I didn't like was that the added
something called a sham blur and it
doesn't matter what game you play the
Sham blur originated and quake won and
it was goddamn terrifying I'll tell you
that was that heard something something
something on write something batteries
are getting low no it's not better
charge I want to go to bed tonight okay
I'll venture upstairs nothing going on
here I thought this was supposed to be
this Ridge oh oh it's you again
stop getting blood on my walls unless
his artistic interpretation nothing
nothing nothing
whole lot of nothing no I don't have
time to check that that's my computer
downstairs I think baby holy hell
stupid baby go away like you oh man damn
baby oh oh oh
get to bed sprint you dick come on hmm
hello is anybody out there
a new day and new hauntings there better
be I supposed to be the abridged version
oh what a relaxing night sleep
how are you doing baby you still in here
oh okay alright he's saying it's women
that's the code two three five yeah
and then everything goes either I had a
bad night we know Michael okay now I got
the code edit can I get out please
that's real cool and all the way that is
that way what's that picture again
who's it appear I know wat da oh hello
somebody there
[Music]
no no okay all right Oh God I remember
Hugh get out of my way
excuse me okay move dick Scooby yeah
thank you yeah run away I got mail get
mine oh I don't have enough things to do
I can't sprint them more than two inches
can I get all down TV is this guy
watching porn again what egg was that oh
no oh okay I've got mail kid oh that's
not good man
ah hey what the hell my boxes go take my
boxes hey that's mine hey stop that
well hey hey that's just that's my box
that's my box there are many like it but
all of these are mine given that it's my
household hey fall down
oh it's careful I want to you can't tell
me what to do it's an ugly little
mannequin kind of freaky
now it's freaky it's my video but time
for you okay so that was something
alright let's go back in the kitchen s
pose I guess I can open this safe let me
I'll do that after I get the picture
anything else in here
dammit who leaves the water running
house is evil hey put the chairs up well
thank you for one but who who did this
anybody no not gonna fess up your crimes
seems awfully suspicious
hmmm clicking on my computer
we're knock this down this is obviously
not
Luke don't know what that is but I'm
running out of battery real quick seems
like I'm running out a better quicker I
just got down here I gotta go back
upstairs again what the hell
this battery sucks man there's not even
of time to scare me oh hi excuse me my
battery's about to die and ergo me
alright so far nothing really new
besides those boxes moving someone's
clicking something I'll open the yeah I
don't have time to read all that you
know okay what does it change or did
that just get lit up alright anything in
the bathroom wake up something was
different
oh so much in the lineup who did that oh
oh oh gonna die sprint please okay now
so far there hasn't been anything new
like a few sit what wha
okay I don't know what that was all
about okay
rise and shine there Johnny boy whatever
your name is
I'm gonna call you dick
okay don't sleep obviously after this
one I can't sleep now so I guess I got
[Music]
[Applause]
change hey my couch is loading no no
stop no I don't take no hey two three
maybe that can't be the key to the base
aw damn straight
give me that all right anybody gonna try
to stop me from going down to the
basement was that that was out there
someone's screwing with my oh nice dog
dad whoa hello what then I can't move oh
okay
oh good thing again hi how you doing
someone's clicking around on my computer
hey I'm actually running out of time I'm
gonna do another piece part of this just
just to make sure there's nothing new
but so far it's spent all this money DUP
hi so cool so anyway I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna play another round but this is
all the time I got for this episode
thank you so much for watching click the
annotate some more videos - that one
I've done and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye bye